hey guys i'm david now the fallout 4 is
finally in our hands and in our consoles
i'm going to cast an eye on fallout
future bringing fallout 4 mods from pc
to the console versions of the RPG is a
big deal and is something that Bethesda
has wanted to do with its game since the
days of the Elder Scrolls morrowind more
than 10 years ago that's according to
Bethesda marketing executive Pete Hines
who talked more about Bethesda's plans
for modding in a new video interview
with Microsoft's Larry Major Nelson herb
it's a big deal hein said it's something
that Todd Howard has talked about for
years since back of morrowind in 2002
modding is something we've always
supported with all the bethesda game
studio tools what's different in fallout
4 however is the game's mods at least
some of them will be playable on Xbox
one and PlayStation 4 the fallout for
Creation Kit the tool suite the pc
players use to make the mods will launch
in early 2016 for pc with supported mods
coming to xbox one sometime later the
functionality is expected to launch on
clears for further into the future Hines
didn't go into specifics about how
fallout 4s pc mods will work on console
but they talked at a high level but
Perez's idea for how it hopes the system
will function you want to do it in a way
that's easy hind said this is not about
you have to have a PC you have to do it
yourself the idea is you go to play the
game and there's a menu option you click
on it and there's a bunch of stuff you
to download you click on the stuff you
want you start playing the game with
these new mods we want it to be a really
streamlined fun experience there's still
specifics we have to work out but it's
part of our post launch plan hi in
summation of habit as de would like to
see fallout 4 mods work on console
sounds a lot like how the modding system
for scaring works on pc with the Steam
Workshop why Microsoft there are a
company that is in both spaces they're
heavily in the PC space they're heavily
in the console space and they had some
good ideas about how to make something
like this work so what mods are you
looking forward to in the world of
Fallout 4 let us know in the comments
below I'm Dave you can follow me on
twitter at a regular dave and for all
your fallout content stay tuned to
gamespot com